so a long time ago i was on call in a
neonatal intensive care unit in a
children's hospital
and a friend of mine kevin kelly came
over during the middle of the night to
see what it's like to be a doctor on
call
and as we made our way through the
corridors between the little incubators
isolettes of babies being kept
temperature controlled
i didn't want to disturb them didn't
open the isolettes didn't wake them up
but made a number of critical changes in
their medical treatment based on their
lab values and what i saw on the
monitors
kevin turned to me and said
so basically
what i'm observing is that all you do is
manage data
that's what being a doctor is now i was
pretty taken aback because i thought
wait there's a lot more to it than that
right there's the human touch and
there's wisdom but the more i thought
about it
the more i saw yes those other things
were important but that managing data
is critical to health decisions
and i spent a lot of my career ever
since then trying to liberate health
data trying to get data in the hands of
clinicians in the first place to make
decisions getting data in the hands of
patients getting data in the hands of
everyone trying to help foment a culture
of participatory medicine because having
the data is critical to health decisions
well today what i want to do is to with
your help
destroy
one of the most cherished icons of
clinical data
i want to end the one piece of clinical
data that most people believe is true
and that's to end the idea that 98.6 is
the human body temperature
it first happened in paper in 1868 there
was a guy named carl
reinhold auguste wunderlich brilliant
paper
where he declared 98.6 was the normal
normal human body temperature was
actually a great paper he showed that he
was the first guy to really get the idea
that fever was not an illness if you
looked at the bills of mortality like
jay walker's from his library i couldn't
quite see it from my seat but it looked
like fever was one of the leading causes
of death right behind plague and
throughout many different places in
history fever was an illness and he got
that fever was data and he called it a
symptom or a sign or clue to what was
going on in the body
so there's several reasons for
destroying this idea a 98.6 is normal
one it's just an average and none of
most of us are not average
number two it's the wrong average it's
not 98.6
number three the idea of an average
isn't very useful because average for a
one month old is different than a
two-month-old it's different than a
three-month-old it's different than a 40
year old or 70 year old it's different
for men and women it's different if
you're taking birth control it's
different if you're an athlete
so the idea of average doesn't make
sense but the real reason to destroy it
is that temperature is not a point
it's not even a line
the idea we need to get out is that
temperature is a wave form
it changes throughout the day normally
it rises and falls often by a degree or
two throughout the day
so for me for instance at 4 00 am 99
degrees would be a fever but at 4 pm
it'd be perfectly normal
it's not the number it's the curve that
matters that curve changes during the
day it changes throughout the course of
the year not just the average but the
shape of the curve changes when the the
low points are and when the high points
are change
and it changes in the day if you were a
parent in the morning you could wake up
and take a temperature of a child that
was quote unquote normal but actually
showed you the curve was off for that
child and that later in the day you'll
know they have a fever you can keep them
home now
or for my father who is
a senior now for him a 98.6 could be the
sign it could be a fever the sign of a
life-threatening infection but this idea
of a point in time being normal misses
it entirely
so i work at scanadu where we have a
bunch of really amazing scientists doing
cutting-edge stuff developing medical
devices for the next generation to
really put data in the hands of people
beyond what what we've seen and i want
to demo for you today just one little
piece on that journey an educational
device called scout and demo on kevin
just because that would be so fun
let me open up the scout here
this is that has to turn it on and
connect the bluetooth
this is a little thing
made of plastic it looks like not very
pretty printed yes yes 3d printed
prototype so
um
i'm going to cover this i'm going to
hold it here right that's right so with
one finger he's covering uh
a little window motor sensor and a
little metal thing that i'm holding here
yeah and it's got like a little
electronic of some sort right yes hold
on just a second you're not connected to
bluetooth there you are
so
i'm using my left hand you're using your
left hand because you're completing a
circle i'm making a circuit of some sort
right that goes through your finger all
the way around to your forehead and i'm
gonna put it on my temple here i'm not
gonna press it into my head right just
put it on my head just put it on your
head in our feed turned off
look on here yeah
so there's little uh
little squiggly lines on the on the
phone
is that that is correct i'm not sure why
it's not showing on the screen
but what
can we get the screen back up or can you
zoom in on the phone zoom in on the
phone
oh here we go
we back up and rescan here too there we
go so skin again
the red line is uh heart heart beat ecg
and the green line is ppg or plasma
platysma graph that's looking at the
fluctuations in the
in the blood vessels and the vertical
lines there are noise from the stage
somehow
your heart rate shot up oh yeah
it was 56 before
but the basic idea is that that
technologies like this where see when
wunderlich did his things his
thermometer was over a foot long and and
took 20 minutes to get a reading and now
it's easy to get readings fast on your
vitals and now with with cell phones
with the analytics like stephen wolfram
was talking about you can actually plot
curves this is a 24-hour curve a 7-day
average of a 24-hour curve and shows
what a temperature might look like and
one temperature that could be normal at
another time could be completely
abnormal in another so we want to blow
away the idea of a point in time being
accurate for temperature but the same is
true for most things for blood pressure
it's a curve that varies on different
things during the day cholesterol level
know your numbers it's a curve it's not
not one number and it changes throughout
the day and by getting our curves
together it's not just living by the
numbers that's foundational but now it's
living by calculus learning the changes
in the curves and we have the analytics
to do it where we can understand our
personal health ecology thanks very much